[Music]
my mouth i have no control happy friday
so if there's anything we learn from
covid it's that our leaders and experts
lie and they suck
that's it goodnight everybody
first a leader so-called leader vp
kamala harris or as joe calls her
president harris now she attempts to
string some words together like chief
half blinking christmas lights and she's
the dimmest bulb
six former
administration officials last week wrote
that open letter urging the
administration to change course to
change strategy
is it time
it is time for us to
do what we have been doing and that time
is every day
every day it is time for us to agree
that
there are things and tools that are
available to us to slow this thing down
that time is every day
wow it's like a song lyric
that's not word salad that's a turd
salad with a vinaigrette of voder regret
she just starts talking hoping the words
line up like kids at the school
cafeteria but instead they scatter like
a deck of cards in a strong wind two
metaphors tied together
[Laughter]
it's funny the dems were hoping her
youthful enthusiasm would rub off and
biden which is hard to do because
they've only been in the same room twice
in the last year
but instead biden's incoherence has
rubbed off on her apparently it's as
contagious as omicron here's a
comparison
count the vote
count the vote
count the vote i urge people to you can
google it or go on to any search engine
and find out where free testing and the
free testing site is available and to
help
lead our federal testing program
i've talked i've i've taught i've
excused me i've tapped uh dr tom
i hope i pronounced it and angel
angles me
correct i have to look at the current
information i think it's going to be by
next week but soon absolutely soon and
it is a matter of urgency for us should
we have done that sooner we are doing it
but should we have done it sooner we are
doing it yeah
wow
it's like she caught a new variant call
it joe macron it rots the brains of
mediocre politicians now when do they
inspire as much confidence as a doctor
would in the operating room wearing a
female body inspector t-shirt
speaking of doctors this week we found
out that our top scientists thought
covet did in fact leak from a lab but
they were too worried that further
debate would harm science in china
yeah because the last thing we want to
do is bring a halt to those lab
experiments they're doing on caged
poodles and uyghurs
this according to recently surfaced
emails in which one expert admits
from nearly a year ago that a likely
explanation was that covet had rapidly
evolved in a low security lab
yeah a low security lab you know maybe
it's me but that sounds like the worst
kind of lab
at least for messing around with deadly
viruses
cat follows better safety protocols when
she makes meth in her garage
[Laughter]
the email to fauci and dr francis
collins of the nih
suggests a virus was primed for rapid
transmission between humans
that's a pretty big whoops even bigger
than the daily one in biden's slacks
so what did the experts do did they leap
into action to get the truth out
fat chance my friday friends they
fretted that even debating gain of
function research would do unnecessary
harm to science in general and science
in china in particular
francis collins warned it could damage
international harmony that's right they
kept it quiet not to protect you but to
protect the feelings of the brutal lying
dictatorship that's as sensitive as a
chubby kid on tick-tock
speaking of harmony
what was collins the former head of the
nih doing rather than telling us the
truth
this
song
past the pandemic
when
we're
free
there's a
life i remember
full of activity
you know i'm looking at the signer over
there and i'm thinking you know this is
a time when i envy the deaf
i think my ears are going to charge me
with murder so yeah nero fiddled while
rome burned and while a pandemic raged
francis played his guitar like a
camp counselor ruining your s'mores
so the emails revealed that scientists
were less interested in science than
politics and felt it was better to hide
the origins of a deadly virus that be
open with those of us who were about to
die
now there were people like us who knew
the virus likely came from that lab some
were scientists and they were roundly
mocked some were called
yet privately the mocking experts agreed
with them and yet they left the people
who said this publicly hung out to dry
just to protect their own asses and
their own grants they said we were nuts
in tin foil hats that told us to wear
masks in our cars empty parks and
swimming pools
it raises the point just how sane were
the scientists in the first place
they created a deadly virus thinking
they could then reverse
engineer a vaccine in the name of
science well why not just not create the
virus then you don't need to reverse
engineer the vaccine they've already
made vaccines to fight natural viruses
so we really didn't need to invent new
deadlier creepier ones but hey where's
the fun in that if you want to play god
and keep sucking at the government teat
which leads to the bigger question
accountability i'm not saying that this
man-made virus was leaked on purpose
i'm pretty sure no one really wanted to
kill more than 10 million people
but in this arrogant murky universe
experts knew there's a risk you could
leak a deadly man-made virus but they
deemed the risk acceptable and when it
happened they blamed it on the wet
market which is pretty much a gross
version of trader joe's
well just down the road researchers were
bumbling around like a bunch of nutty
professors
how convenient the pandemic had nothing
to do with the scientists say the
scientists and so republicans had to
force their hand to grant access to the
documents after these scientific
institutions repeatedly resisted efforts
to come clean and these emails show that
scientists were already trying to
silence any debate claiming it would
distract top researchers from their
active duties yeah the way a nuclear
weapon heading towards new york would
distract people from going to work so
don't tell them
colin's worried that the voices of
conspiracy will quickly dominate perhaps
because in that case those voices were
right and colin's awful singing can't
drown them out anymore so they covered
up the truth and now we're all covering
our faces
they knew the lab leak was realer than
they let on and now we're left with
millions of dead
call it manslaughter but the crime was
in the gamble they decided to roll the
dice it was an accidental release but
born from a risk that they happily
accepted like a drunk driver getting
into his car
sure someone might get killed but it
probably ain't going to be me they put
their reputations above human lives to
them you weren't much more than the
contents of a petri dish so what's the
punishment for that
hell even in the most liberal crap hole
of a city they'd make you post bail
here
[Applause]
let's welcome tonight's guests
is politics say conservative but his
beard says daddy outspoken
editor-in-chief and contributing editor
at the spectator
trout with more
if she hears one more southern
stereotype she'll slap you with her
possum
fox business anchor dagan mcdowell
democrats say his comedy is worse than
january 6th founder of
theloftist.party.com
michael loftus
and she's proof blondes have more fun if
by fun you mean priors fox news
contributor cat tip
yes
so michael what is worse than your
wardrobe the contact of our so-called
experts or our politicians all of the
above can't they all be equal yes they
can this i find this whole thing uh
deeply disturbing seriously they're
worried about oh this might affect uh
science in china yes i'm gonna invite
them to go to any college campus
uh science in china is going to be just
fine yes they're not gonna they're not
gonna really take a big hit but here's
the thing that i really wanna get into
it's like uh our options were are what
uh accidental leak and bat soup i'm all
for that uh that third rail that whole
hey let's do this on purpose right like
they keep dialing up these different
viruses this one just seemed too perfect
it's like this one kills redheads this
one kills blondes would you like
something in a uh it kills fat diabetics
ooh that sounds lovely could you get
that out right before the election would
that i mean that that is the premise
though was that you know what this is an
actually you know a really valuable
exercise we create the killer so we can
figure out how to stop the killer but
the problem is they they created the
killer and the killer got loose it
almost sounds like a movie dagen
you know what if people watched more
movies about in the
80s then we would this would never have
happened and let me explain what
happened to our healthy
fear of communism in communist countries
wanting to wipe the united states off of
the face of the earth take away our
luscious freedoms like my parents raised
me to be well fear the soviet union they
had nukes they hated america i watched
rocky and bullwinkle boris and natasha
taught me really you know moleskill
moose and squirrel wear moose and
squirrel and then
1984 best movie maybe ever red dawn
of course c thomas howe gave me the
tingles so that's why i wore out the vhs
tape but again
the soviet union was evil but it wasn't
just the soviet i'm not talking
mccarthyism you know the red scare like
um hunting people down but
we would never like don't these old
coots gordon life foot and tony fauci
don't they realize that this communist
government why would you give them money
if you knew that they were going to do
experiments in a lab that wasn't safe
which we knew about low level i mean
right at least make it a high level lap
how hard is that they want to destroy
the united states and if they had you
know my knowledge from say patrick
swayze movies yeah
this would never have happened
just put that little weather stripping
in the windows it's like it's 70 bucks
and is this the only lab in china that
doesn't have security cameras
like we don't know what happened
so this is the this is the question
chadwick that i haven't heard asked okay
so i'm not talking about premeditated
murder i'm talking about negligence
nobody wants the fouchy and all that
they didn't want to kill a bunch of
people they thought they thought in
their heads that they were saving future
lives right so they were doing god's
work so to speak you know they were like
they were saving millions by creating
ways to but instead 10 million
lush they did it in a careless lab in a
careless way
what kind of accountability is there is
there i'm putting this out i mean is
there like
death penalty for the the you know i
don't know i don't know i'm just
putting that out there
it's not for me to say because
something's got to happen something's
got to happen but i don't even know
i don't even know who you arrest and
that's another question we'll get to but
like who do you charge i mean well you
know we know what the penalty over
treason is in this country it's supposed
to be but i won't say that on television
uh i don't know what's the next logical
thing to happen would be an
international treaty against gain of
function research of this type but
nobody's even talking about that it
doesn't seem like that's even on the
table because
science is winning you know we have to
keep the research going i was most
surprised to learn about this
international harmony that we apparently
have is this yeah i know
and it's just you know it's so fragile
we've had it for so long i guess the
next time there's a a genocide occurring
what do we do to make sure that doesn't
disrupt the international harmony do you
have a jam session yeah
yeah
i think this calls for a drum service
yeah
that's the attitude people in like
abusive relationships have like i know
i'm being horribly mistreated but i
wouldn't want to disrupt the harmony and
then like the massive gaslighting that
all of us were subjected to like if
anybody for a while dared to say hey
this virus that broke up and this broke
out in the same neighborhood as this lab
full of viruses maybe came from the lab
full of viruses they were like you're
insane you are so crazy that you're
crazy is dangerous and i banish you from
the online like
gaslighting it's crazy it was it was so
funny because i don't know if it was
here in the five i said what are the
odds this has got to be almost two years
ago what what are the odds that it broke
out where the lab was
and like people like that would get
picked up and they would call me crazy
and then also if you just mentioned the
name china
a link to the lab then you were racist
but you could say this was always weird
about this whole thing that made me
think it was a cover-up
if you said the chinese lab that was
racist but if you said the wuhan market
which was a chinese market that wasn't
racist
when in fact that's actually more racist
because you're attributing it to a
cultural practice and it really is a
farmer's market the reason why it's wet
is because they hose down the ground
after they chop up the meat and most of
it is stuff that you eat there's a few
exotic animals here and there and
they're not that good
take it from me
but anyway they just need to get the
water after when they hose it down
that's when it's good everything's all
mixed together
yes you know what the thing is so here's
the other reason why a lot of people
didn't want to blame china and i again i
must have said this two years ago i
don't know when it can't be two years
ago let's say 18 months
it's not just about them because we
sponsor it so we can't say we can't say
ah it's evil china we're there so that
means if you were to do a lawsuit you
couldn't just sue china you'd have to
sue the united states you'd have to
because it was sponsored there's
sponsorships in the u.s values like you
know oversaw this you know the the
research funding
we like that we like that lab so it's
gonna be on uh we went i think we went
to that lab anyway
read the book viral by matt ridley we
had him on here he nailed this thing
down it's like insane
and it's just i don't know what to do
it's crazy accountability hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else